I've been shown a contract that's
purportedly between Iran and Russia for
the sale of Iranian ammunition samples
of different sizes of tank artillery
shells and Rockets have also been shown
this supplement to an allegedly related
contract also for ammunition But it
includes the barrel of a gun for a tank
and an artillery piece they both got the
same date the 14th of September 2022
this one is worth around 750
000 while this one is worth just over a
million dollars now the source that
shared them with me claimed that they're
a hundred percent authentic Sky News
hasn't been able to independently verify
that claim I've gone to the Iranian
Embassy here in London and the Russian
Embassy here to ask for a comment they
haven't yet responded I've also shared
this with experts though and they say
that they believe the content is
plausible